Okay Dr. Tyson, in your opinion, who would be the most
scientifically accurate and believable
superhero with superhuman abilities in
relation to real-world physics and
counterpoint the most unbelievable and
inaccurate and why. So he is coming
to us from Brisbane Australia oh cool.
Neil: So I think the most reachable superhero
that's out there is Batman because he
uses real devices on his utility belt
and there's nothing there you just
say "oh that can't happen" or "you couldn't
have done that" or you know. Yeah he's got
some special materials but that's
okay because his company makes
Chuck: He's a millionaire.
Neil: Yeah, he's a billionaire.
Chuck: And his company is working for the government at
developing experimental technology.
Neil: And he's got stuff that you don't have.
So for me he's the most
realistic superhero, and Robin as well.
He's just an acrobat in tights, okay.
Chuck: at least that's their cover.
Mmhm, oh you know we know the deal. Hangin' around with that young boy all the time
Putting him in underwear, living at your house, your big
billionaire mansion. We know the deal! Oh yes, that's my young ward.
Oh is that what you call him? No,
your young ward. Oh, okay.
Okay, child services won't be calm
because you're a billionaire and you
have a young ward okay? Let me do that, I
am up on charges.
Neil: I swear I've never thought about it that
way, nor did I ever think that Bert and
Ernie were a gay couple, you know. You know there's a whole... or the
Tinky-Winky was the gay one out of the...
you know. There's a whole
literature on... Chuck: but right exactly, who and what might be gay.
Neil: Who and what might mean.
So I forgot what I was talking about.
Chuck: So you were saying that he is the most realistic, Batman.
Neil: He's more real than Iron Man because the
energy source that Iron Man is drawing
from... to concentrate that much energy in
one place, you would basically vaporize
everything it was touching.
Chuck: And the other thing too is when you
think about Tony Stark having this power
source inside his chest, okay let's
be honest. Let's just hook him up to a
city and forget it because that's
amazing. Why is this guy flying
around in a suit instead of powering New York
for free, but go ahead.
Neil: Right, so you can't concentrate energy.
Anything that you've ever used that has
a lot of energy going on with it gets
very hot very quickly.
That's what energy does. If you fire a
gun enough times the gun gets warm and
can even get too hot to touch,
and cannons in the old days. In fact they
used cannons firing cannonballs and the
fact that the cannon kept getting hotter
and hotter to discover and come to an
understanding of how heat worked.
Physicists would say "while you're
fighting this war, can we..."
Chuck: Can we come in here and measure measure? Neil: Right, measure.
And they thought there was a substance called
caloric, which was a fluid that would be
heat. And if you put caloric from one thing
to the other then that thing would be at
a higher temperature, and so there was
there were early ideas were we were
intellectually sort of machinating how
this would work. So Tony Stark, well I
think he could wipe the floor with
Batman. If I had to be one of those
I definitely be Tony Stark.
Chuck: Yeah, because you're both billionaires, so hey why not, right?
Neil: Well no they're both billionaires.
Chuck: That's what I'm saying. Right yeah the both yeah.
Neil: Pick one. Chuck: Pick the billionaire you want to be.
Neil: Right, right. And so definitely but it's
the concentration of energy,
it's not real.